so you're here tonight for the summer  serpentine gallery what are you looking  forward to at the party well I see here  there's a surprise guest which obviously  I'm looking forward to and Lorraine has  been building this beautiful thing all  day which I'm very excited to see and  what we look forward to from you in the  future  lots of things I hope I've got a movie  coming out here in September called cold  comes the night with Bryan Cranston  which I'm very proud of tell us a little  bit more about them it's a thriller a  sort of drama thriller set in the  Catskills about a single mother so it's  a good it's a good movie what's in the  highlight of the year so far for you  Star Trek was an amazing experience I  loved being part of that and I loved  everyone involved that was very special  what's it like working with amazing cars  also amazing directory changes well JJ's  a hero and so it was a real pleasure  working with him  you